en Honduras los cultivadores de
camarones están preocupados en esta
empresa del Sur del país 800 empleados
trabajan limpiando y empacando camarones
que luego serán exportados a Taiwán
México y Europa pero ahora temen que se
detenga el comercio con taipei
queremos que siga siendo
abierto Pues porque nosotros dependemos
de acá de este trabajo y nuestra familia
todo eso tenemos hijos que mantener en
la casa todo eso el mes pasado la
presidenta shumara Castro decidió bajo
presión de Beijing rompe sus relaciones
diplomáticas con la isla En nombre del
principio de una sola china como
consecuencia Taiwán podría negarse a
comprar productos hondureños mire perder
el mercado taiwanés para Honduras como
productor de camarones es una situación
muy compleja por el nivel de precios
Taiwán es un mercado de alto valor donde
nuestros camarones se pueden vender casi
que el doble con respecto al mercado
chino la asociación Nacional de
acuicultura es de Honduras pidió al
gobierno hondureño mantener el tratado
de libre comercio firmado en 2008 con
Taiwán por eso solicitamos de una manera
muy muy respetuosa que nos permitan
tener el tratado de libre comercio con
Taiwán abierto
el cual permite continuar exportando y
que no se detenga la exportaciones y no
se afecten los trabajos en la zona sur
el camarón es el quinto producto
agroalimentario de exportación de
Honduras y Taiwán es el mayor mercado de
estos moluscos Ahora sólo 13 estados en
el mundo mantienen relaciones oficiales
con la isla